[Music]  downstream  we are i can't believe this  okay i'm gonna i'm gonna make this  really quick  absolutely the floor is yours so you  expect me to play you  now after you go on stream earlier today  insulting me saying that i'm running  away  that i'm scared to play you let me tell  you one thing  i was a gm i was a world champion  when you were doing pee pee in your  pampers  that's all right that's all i have to i  have to say  and after yesterday we play a few  nice games i give you some tips  and you go ahead flag me in one game  until  then i'm telling you go in your car  play from your phone you don't do it  instead you go crash the server and mess  up  everybody's day you're you're you're  you're not a good man